So far,
you've researched browser events, and
you've taken a peek
at them being logged.
Now it's time to actually listen for
and respond to them with jQuery.
There are three items you need in order
to listen for events and react to them.
You need the target element to listen
to, the event we want to react to,
and the actions to take in response.
Let me show you an example.
I need the target element that
jQuery will be listening to for
events, so I'll use jQuery
to select the input field.
Next, I call the .on() method.
This .on method is where
the magic happens.
It's the primary way the jQuery
uses to set up event listeners.
The first argument to the .on method
is the event I want to listen for.
In this example, it's keypress.
But it could also be click, change,
and mouseover to name a few.
And finally,
I need to pass a function with the
actions I want to happen in response.
This function is called the .callback.
The .callback function being
passed to the .on method,
is just a regular JavaScript function.
And therefore, can contain
any JavaScript code you want,
from altering page content
to analytics code.
I'll change the contents of the function
to alter the color of the page.
And I'll test it.
Bam.
Looks good.
In the next quiz, you're going to
create your own event listener.